let's go to voicemail we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p here's a voicemail
that's sort of funny but it relates to
something we've been thinking about take
a listen hey David Joe from California
hey have you thought about doing a tour
meaning say you take a month and you
travel the different central areas where
you have listeners we can meet up you do
a live broadcast show from there at the
same time do maybe a voter registration
drive I have a live guest there and
agreed and at the same time still
submerged so that would be cool have you
thought of that
hi David yeah so I love the idea I would
love to get to different parts of the
country including parts of the country I
don't typically get to meet viewers do
live shows all that stuff the concerns
are more practical number one the amount
of logistics for a tour and I know
people who have done tours the logistics
are crazy so if we were to handle it
internally it would be almost crippling
because of the amount of stuff that
would not get done because we're dealing
with the tour logistics so we are I'm
talking to my agent my agent came to me
a couple weeks ago actually and said hey
I want to go and talk to an actual tour
management company where they would set
up everything so you don't have to deal
with it you would just have to show up
that would make it much more feasible
and my manager is actually talking about
doing it with some other a progressive
hosts that whose names certainly you
would recognize that would be very
interesting the other thing is you know
taking a month off from the show is
basically a non-starter doing the show
on the road in addition to events is um
that's another set of logistics and the
show is best when I'm in the studio
that's the reality I'm not even sure if
I'm going to the conventions this summer
because the best show would be me being
here
having reporters there doing live
coverage via video whenever we're at
events I do feel like the content
actually suffers to some degree so
that's another question if we were to do
it like a month-long tour the other
possibility is to only do events around
weekends like Thursday Friday Saturday
events and travel back and forth
every week that is a big undertaking as
well so we're looking into the tour
thing I would love to do it at a
personal level I think it would be great
it's the the devil is in the details as
the kids these days like to say that
does it for today we've got a great
bonus show coming up for you get instant
access by becoming a member or a patron
I will speak to you then or until
tonight's live Iowa caucus results
stream on YouTube twitch and Facebook
see you then on the bonus show or just
tomorrow if you want to be boring about
it